ce sera sa quatrième participation à la
route du rhum louis burton leur embolie
temps plus précisément là celle les
bordes et avait côté alors louis comment
ça se passe est-ce que ça va bien à
quelques jours du départ qui sera donné
je le précise le 6 novembre prochain
depuis saint malo ben écoute tout va
très bien là on est on est à paris pour
la conférence de presse de la route du
rhum c'est le moment où ça lance les
hostilités
on a bien travaillé sur le bateau là
qu'ils retournent à l'eau maintenant
j'étais la semaine dernière le week-end
dernier au bar n'a bonnel on a été
écouté le brame des cerfs côté de la
scène déborde voilà on essaie de se
faire des bons moments comme ça et du
coup le bateau il répond comment pour
cette route du rhum et ben super bien
c'est c'est un avantage d'avoir cette
machine là depuis 18 mois d'avoir pu pas
mal navigué avec avoir fait les épreuves
du championnat du monde en solitaire
cette année au premier semestre donc je
suis je suis très content il y avait des
petites choses encore amélioré qu'on a
eu le temps d'améliorer cet été voilà
donc à une concurrence féroce un plateau
avec des supers main mais mais je suis
assez assez satisfait pour l'instant
assez optimiste on en discute et un
petit peu avant avant le début de cette
interview peut-être un top 5 c'est ça
c'est l'objectif pour cette troupe du
rhône bah oui on cherche toujours à vous
cherche toujours à s'améliorer alors
j'ai été dans le top 5 qu'une cinquième
place en 2014 en classe imoca donc
j'aimerais bien pas faire moins bien que
ce à quoi mais bon il faut déjà terminée
c'est c'est une composante importante
terminer une course et puis du coup
gérer la zone rouge pas cassé et viser
la meilleure place à l'arrivée et
quelles sont les recettes justement pour
réussir une route comme la route du rhum
c'est quand même un sprint on peut le
dire c'est d'un point a à un point b il
faut y aller très vite en 7 jours 10
jours alors que sur un vendée globe par
exemple faut être beaucoup plus long
c'est un marathon là c'est un sprint par
contre oui tout à fait c'est un sprint
du coup ben ça veut dire qu'on met les
bateaux à rude épreuve on les pousse on
pousse aussi le skipper dans ses
retranchements avec moins de sommeil par
cycle de 24 heures donc le secret c'est
déjà une très bonne préparation essayé
de laisser de rien laisser au hasard
donc moi j'ai une top équipe qui me suit
pour le bateau bureau vallée depuis
plusieurs années donc on a essayé de
penser à tout ça c'est vraiment
important et puis après c'est une
histoire de calibration de pas pousser
trop loin dans la zone rouge et limiter
les risques de casse il faut un peu de
réussite un peu de chance parce que
c'est un sport mécanique au milieu des
éléments dont il peut se passer plein de
choses c'est un sprint ton bateau va
vite c'est un sprint oui mon bateau va
très vite à peu près à toutes les
allures donc donc c'est assez
intéressant ça ou le jeu ça veut dire
que on va pouvoir probablement tenter d
option un peu différente et compter sur
une machine qui va vite c'est important
ça permet de lever le pied comme c'est
nécessaire et ensuite d'être plein gaz
je disais à précédemment c'est un
quatrième participation tu avais
participé à la 2010 2014 2018 maintenant
2022 en 2010 tu n'étais pas sur la même
catégorie par contre en 2014 taille
finit 5e et en 2018 tu as va abandonner
tu as vu un peu tous les cas de figure
un si je comprends bien ouais en 2010
c'était ma première grande course au
large donc ça avait lancé ma carrière et
2014 top-5 génial 2018 je suis un peu
dans la même configuration que la cette
année avec ce nouveau bateau on venait
de racheter l'ancien banque populaire a
après le vendée globe 2017 on avait fait
une saison qui s'était bien passé en
2017 avec servane que la jacques vabre
et je partais en 2018 avec un bateau que
je connaissais un peu moins bien que
celui là parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
toutes ces épreuves avant et puis ben je
suis parti très fort et est il ya une
pièce cap a tenu un fol qui a arraché
une pièce du bateau fait une voie d'eau
j'ai commencé à couler j'étais obligé de
rentrer voilà donc faut vraiment
vraiment trouver là
le bon curseur pour pas abîmer pas
casser sur la dernière transat aussi tu
es tu vas à bordeaux n'est assez
rapidement comment tu comment tu vas
faire pour pour donner le maximum encore
une nouvelle fois
ben là c'est vrai que c'est un ce
démâtage c'était la première fois que ça
arrivait en 12 ans et c'est très
surprenant c'est assez violent
on a d'abord cherché à comprendre ce qui
s'était passé au niveau des hauts
niveaux des pièces au niveau de la
technique et donc on a fait le
nécessaire pour que ça ne puisse plus
arriver c'est des histoires de tension
de câbles qui tiennent le mât et voilà
on a bien contrôlé tous ces aspects là
et puis me plains dalle armes qui vont
me permettre de savoir justement s'il ya
trop de tensions pas assez etc on a
beaucoup travaillé sur ces aspects là
pour pas que ce genre de cas de figure
se représente alors tu évinois mais tu
es également de saint malo c'est là-bas
que que tu peaufine sa préparation à
saint malo là tu seras domicile oui tout
à fait c'est un vrai avantage je pense
surtout que 137 bateau ou c'est en 38
bateaux sur un départ de course c'est
énorme
ça veut dire beaucoup de monde ça veut
dire beaucoup de pression ça veut dire
tout devient compliqué se déplacer dans
la ville allait rejoindre nos bateaux
etc
et de pouvoir gérer ça en ayant sa
maison se console son cocon familial nos
locaux avec notre entreprise sur le port
et où ben c'est un vrai avantage mine de
rien ça va permettre de pouvoir faire
face à toutes les obligations et en même
temps se reposer avoir des moments of
puis on dort mieux chez soi qu'à l'hôtel
donc voilà c'est c'est sûr que je pars
avec cet avantage là je suis le seul de
la classe imoca à pouvoir bénéficier de
ça puisque je suis le seul à saint malo
donc on va capitaliser là dessus y'a pas
être plus de pression juste avant haye a
envie de bien faire ça c'est sûr c'est
sûr puisque ont toute l'année on va à la
rencontre des scolaires donc bah y'a
plein de plein d'école plein d'enfants
qui sont derrière derrière le bateau
on a on a fait une très belle place au
dernier vendée globe donc on en est on
ils en accueillent des malouins énorme
beaucoup d'espoir maintenant repose sur
nos épaules mais voilà c'est très
motivant c'est une bonne pression c'est
une pression une pression positive à la
question qu'est-ce qu'on peut te
souhaiter louis pour cette route du rhum
2022 ah ben un truc dans l'absolu c'est
c'est de se retrouver de l'autre côté en
guadeloupe et puis si possible sur un
podium et boire du rhum ensemble et
boire du rhum ensemble ouais merci
beaucoup à louis burton je leur rappelle
la route du rhum commencera le 6
novembre prochain depuis saint malo